future 21 national monuments is under
federal review this morning President
Trump is expected soon to significantly
downgrade some of them in size and in
scope the grand staircase-escalante
national monument that's in utah could
shrink by 40 to 60 percent and that's a
bigger area than the whole state of
Rhode Island
many scientists worry though that the
move could damage one of the richest
deposits of dinosaur bones in the world
what I have ETL went on a dig to see the
concerns about the potential changes
firsthand one to paleontologist called
this flipping the jacket and it's one of
the most nerve-racking moments of their
job you're worried you can damage it
yeah I really am
but for dr. Alan Titus it's also the
reward for all his hard work oh my god
we just exposed more bone yeah yeah
that's Tyrannosaur bone right there
Titus is the paleontologist for the
Grand staircase-escalante national
monument in southern Utah so that bone
right there is 75 million years old and
some change yeah and today he's
unearthing part of a site he thinks
contains four or five ancestors of the
mighty Tyrannosaurus Rex does it feel
like you struck gold yes yeah you
actually are emotional about it I get
very emotional but I get excited about
this kind of stuff and there's a lot for
him to get excited about in the two
decades since the 1.9 million acre patch
of desert was designated a National
Monument 25 new species of dinosaurs
have been discovered in its sands when
this area became designated a National
Monument was that a catalyst yeah when
Grand Circus was created in 1996 it was
originally envisioned that it would be
an outdoor laboratory on this remarkable
site God's handiwork is everywhere in
the fossil record of dinosaurs and other
prehistoric life but that designation by
President Bill Clinton also enraged many
residents of southern Utah who suddenly
were limited in their ability to graze
cattle extract minerals like coal or
even build roads Grand Staircase
National Mining was probably one of the
most volatile
she's in Utah people are still angry
they're still angry yeah rancher Michael
Noll has led the fight against the
monument ever since it was created he
was thrilled earlier this year when
President Trump ordered his interior
secretary Ryan Zinke to review and
likely shrink the size of the monument
opening the land up to more commercial
development means more people can
utilize these lands in the future and it
does not mean selling them off and it
doesn't mean destroy them all the laws
regulations archaeological resource
protection act will all be in place so
these fossils are around 75 million
years old I'm gonna put this okay
paleontologists and eparchy has been
recovering specimens from the monument
for years
if Trump changes its status he fears
there could be more recreational traffic
like off-road vehicles and more chances
for science to suffer you know there's a
possibility that fossils may be lost or
destroyed things like fossil theft and
vandalism once that record of our
planets history is gone you know we've
lost something from the American story
back in his lab Alan Titus stays out of
the political fight after all when it
comes to exploring Grand Staircase land
he's hardly scratched the surface we're
about a fifth of the way through in
essentially more than half of my career
so there's many careers worth of work
left here to do just a document what
lies here in the ground for CBS this
morning media via Al in southern Utah
thank you buddy you know dinosaur bones
not my passion but you can understand
why he's so excited about it they are
cool-looking very cool-looking in quite
old you thinking about going on a dig I
have never done that but I would be
interested in doing that okay you let me
know okay
we have different ideas of fun I see
neuronal